the former senate staffer accusing joe
biden of sexual assault is calling on
the presumptive democratic nominee
to drop out of the presidential race
it's the first time
tara reid has talked publicly since
biden denied the allegation
in the television interview last week ed
o'keefe reports from washington
his campaign is taking this position
that they want all women to be able
to speak safely i have not experienced
that
in an interview with megan kelly tara
reed responded to former vice president
joe biden's denial that he sexually
assaulted her in a capitol hill hallway
in 1993. you should not be running on
character for the president of the
united states you want him to withdraw
i wish he would but he won't but i wish
he would that's how i feel emotionally
do you want an apology i think it's a
little late
reed was one of several women who last
year accused biden of inappropriate
touching
a former senate aide to biden she is the
only person to allege
sexual assault cbs news has spoken to
her several times since she first made
the accusation
in late march we have spoken with
several acquaintances
and her brother who have corroborated
her story but reed's version
and their version of events have evolved
in interviews
with other news outlets i don't really
care if people believe it or not i've
had to live with it
and would she be willing to take a
polygraph test so i will take one if joe
biden takes one
but i'm not a criminal several former
biden candidates have said that they
never heard of reed's allegation at the
time
biden has asked the senate to release
any paperwork that might shed light on
the incident
and he once again denied the allegations
on thursday
well look nothing ever happened with
tara reid
believing women means taking a woman's
claim
seriously when she steps forward and
then vetting it
looking into it in every case the truth
is what matters and in this case
the truth is these claims are flat out
false
late thursday the tribune newspaper in
san luis obispo california
reported that a 1996 court document
shows reid told her ex-husband
about problems with sexual harassment
and then senator biden's office in 1993.
the document doesn't say that biden
committed the harassment
or mention reid's more recent accusation
of assault
in response the biden campaign said in a
statement that as more news outlets
speak to reid and her associates
more and more inconsistencies keep
emerging
cbs news has been trying to get a copy
of that court documents for several days
and we've made repeated requests for an
on-camera interview with tara reid
on thursday biden held the first of what
he's calling virtual campaign events
from his delaware home he spoke with
supporters in florida
a swing state where he has a narrow lead
over president trump
gail all right ed thank you very much